and i want to um introduce our next
speaker
so you for those of you that have been
around for the past
hour or so you already heard but for
those that are just joining now
uh our next speaker is dr rolando he's a
professor in the department of
microbiology and immunology at the
university of california san francisco
he's a virologist and professor
and he is
working on some similar topics
and so we want to um
invite him to present
his perspective on omix and virology
and uh specifically how the pandemic has
also changed uh approaches in that field
so dr andina over to you
thank you leoni
um
let me see you can you see my slides
yes
okay
so this
first slide is um one of these wonderful
experiments of um
particle interference in quantum quantum
mechanics and to me is one of those
examples it's beautiful just just to see
the movie but it it it brings two things
here is one is a time resolution that
we've been discussing uh from from the
very beginning the importance of
understanding that these things are you
know really dynamic the other thing is
that this has um you know it is a very
simple observation
that enables to um develop models that
tell us a lot about the universe and to
me it's a fascinating uh process that we
can understand what happened in the
supernova uh why we have never been
there and will never
be able to um survive there
but
really what i wanted to discuss is you
know science and technology in the time
of pandemics and this is the type of
technology people use in the 14th
century when in in venice uh you know
the um plague um uh hit this uh the
bubonic plague um and really uh right
now what's uh happening is the
technology has changed and where we um
dealing with is and in the 21st century
and a new new type of pandemic epidemics
but now we have uh additional tools and
additional information
that can help us to perhaps and
anticipate predict and uh intervene in a
more effective way
and so
really the concept that we
trying to explore
is how can we integrate
the process the the different layers um
that you will have when you are
um trying to understand various diseases
um and and really you know it goes from
the epidemiology epidemiological
situation to the individual situation to
the tissue situation
and to the single cell
situation and of course at the end of
the day is all about molecules that
somehow interact with each other and
that determine all these levels of um
complexity and the continuum between
these molecules and the epidemiological
effects
they actually broke a break at some
point the question is how can we
integrate how can we connect one layer
with the other it's a little bit the
same with
physics particles and you know
large objects like the apple that
famous apple that fills in and newton's
head you know how do we connect what
happened in our universe with uh what
happened at the particle level and what
we're trying to do in really scratching
the surface here is
both in cell culture and in animal
models
we try to on the one hand understand um
the virus population dynamics
so we're trying to understand how the
virus by sequencing viruses um virus
genomes
you know how the viruses populations
differentiate in different organs so
here we have organ a b and c which may
be the brain and the liver and the
kidney um and
these populations acquire some sort of
signatures and then we can identify it
and that's the experimental data that we
can
collect by sequencing viruses obtained
from different organs
or different conditions in cell culture
then the important thing is statistical
learning that allows us to
classify what are the changes in the
viral genome and
how this um
viral genome is changing over time so to
give us some sort of dynamics normally
we have a classification of the of the
alleles that we see in different organs
you know some will be beneficial some
will be detrimental in the organ a but
in b it could be opposite maybe this the
ones were detrimental and a now are
beneficial in b so understanding this
sort of um you know different
changes and
in integrating that with the global gene
expression
what happened to the ecological niche um
where the virus is replicating what
happened in organ a b and c is what will
give us a little bit more understanding
of what are the forces that are um
the virus is subject to to change when
it goes in a b or c
and you know one of the things that
comes very clear is that if we think
about ecology of infection in other
words the infection as an ecological
process and really the um process inside
of the infected individual as a
intra-host adaptation process really as
an evolutionary process that ecology
has given us give us a lot of guidance
of how to analyze this kind of dynamic
process
really there is a new organism getting
to the beach as it is is modified by the
niche itself because it's changing
over time but it's also modified by
other individuals in that niche
and that's one of the things that i
wanted to discuss is you know how these
defective interference genomes
uh can be playing a role in changing the
outcome of the infection in individuals
infected individuals
now
for all of you you know by now that um
one of the important things in virus
evolution and adaptation
at the small level meaning you know the
virus in a test tube or in an organ
what happened is um the virus acquired
mutations because they're um
enzymes that
duplicate or replicate the genome they
are a little sloppy and they like to be
sloppy and they introduce mutations they
make mistakes and so you you end up with
a bunch of mutations in the genome and
really this is the population of genome
that we call quasi species
um the other
um important mechanism of um doing
replication is recombination
whereas um one
genome here in red is being read by an
enzyme which is a polymerase and at some
point the polymerase decides to leave
this template in red and jump on a bloop
template and so now at the end as a
consequence of that you end up with a
recombinant a little bit of red a little
bit of blue so understanding
the interaction between mutations and
recombination
is critical to understand diversity in
the virus population
and then there is selection so evolution
works as diversity and
the product of diversity and selection
and of course many of these genomes here
they are not viable they have little
mutations and
some of them gets
selected over time
using
sequencing uh you you can now start to
classify mutations that you observe in
these populations um as a little
deleterious
neutral if they don't change the fitness
or beneficial in a particular
environment and of course this
is um these mutations are important to
classify not only
you cannot
again is the case of the dynamics of
this process is very important
and the question is this happened at a
very micro evolution level this happened
at the level of the virus the virus
replicated in a particular cell is
introducing this mutation recombining
and being selected but how that reflects
what happened in a global pandemic
that's a big question
and can we use
data obtained in a very well defined
experimental conditions to
understand
um and predict uh how a pandemic will um
evolve
how you know is this virus is gonna
evolve or can you anticipate you know
whether it's gonna be what would be the
next pandemic that's a big big big
question and i think the answer really
is most people would say there is so
much much
stochastical stochastic stochasticity in
this process that the prediction will be
very hard
but i think if one can reduce the
problem to say these are the things that
cannot happen
we don't know exactly what's going to
happen but we know that the virus cannot
go in this trajectory and i think this
is an interesting challenge for all of
us
we developed and i remember
back
uh in uh i think it was
2012 or something that we uh sit
together we learn it in this
coffee shop in the wildman institute in
recovery in israel and discuss about
this technology and leonid in i think in
24 hours developed an algorithm that
allows to move forward much faster and
more efficiently let me just walk you
through what this idea is
one of the problems in
biology is that we have experimental
noise and sequencing has an experimental
noise meaning that every time you
sequence
the dna the machine that is sequencing
the dna is introducing mutations and at
the end of the day you don't know
whether these mutations were in the
viral genome or were introduced by
mistakes on during sequencing
so what we applied here is one
technology that we call circular
sequencing or 0sec
but basically is is we circularize the
viral rna
and these circles can be used as a
template to create standing repeats when
you do your cdna synthesis which is the
first step that you need to do for
sequencing then you put the cdnas that
are linked together because they've been
producing this circular template and now
you can do consensus of you know really
consensus sequence of all these repeats
and so mutations that are in all the
repeats
um
now are predicted to have been in the
original template this reduced the the
error of sequencing because you identify
mutations that were generated there
randomly and it allows us to to reduce
the noise very very much you know every
time you read this is multiply the error
of sequencing
several times so say elevate it to the
number of times that you read these
repeats
this allows you to not only identify
many mutations that
are present at high frequency in the
population permanent mutations like
lethal mutations
that are
not present in the population can be
also identified and those little
mutations are important
because this allows you to say the
viruses will never acquire this mutation
and maybe these
regions that cannot change there are
good in variance regions that you can
target pharmacologically for example
so what happened with the
sars score 2 i know that many of us all
of us i guess have been very much
affected by this pandemic and we all
you know starting to get more familiar
with terms like mutations and surface
proteins and the spike and antibodies
and so on so i just wanted to you know
bring this um uh this uh things a little
bit because um you know everybody's
interested and i wanted to use it as an
example of how can you use
the bioinformatic and omics to
understand pandemic and maybe generate
effective interventions
this is the situation the globally and
the u.s you see these peaks that appear
on number of cases and this is
consistent with a number of deaths
and a vaccine has been deployed as in
the beginning of 2021 and you can see
that vaccines are effective and yet
there is again a spike and and those
spikes emerge uh no
for a number of reasons one is because
not everybody gets vaccinated
two because the vaccines are not 100
effective particularly not effective at
preventing transmission
and and three uh because the virus is
changing
based on the on the uh
you know uh
challenge uh that the virus have in
terms of transmission replicating and be
successful at replication uh you know
the virus is changing
and uh really the the the the the
critical thing in in any of these
viruses uh transmission is the ability
of the virus to be transmitted from one
individual to other but as i said you
know the virus that you um
acquire is different than the virus that
populate the different organs is
probably uh different than the virus
that really cause the disease uh because
in in many ways those viruses needs to
adapt to a particular organ for example
in sex in the case of south corona
viruses we know is a very complex
disease that not only replicates in
lungs but also replicates and produce
inflammatory effects in
in pancreas and in the heart um and you
know so we don't really understand many
of this and in part is because we don't
we don't understand this
adaptive capacity of the virus and the
same thing with transmission you know
what happened with the new strains
um
this is an example for example in the uk
uh where you see that there was this
strain here replicating until you know
november 2020
and then there is another strain that
replaced the previous one so the
question is uh this strain what is the
the the why is this string replacing the
previous one probably is more fit and
that's a logical
conclusion
but but really the question is why is
more fit and many people are focusing on
this particular interaction and in my
mind it's a little bit
a little bit minimalistic and a little
bit maybe
you know unrealistic to just think that
the only thing that can guide the virus
to be more fit is the interaction
between the receptor
called ac2 and the spike this is the
little protein that is in the surface of
the virus and many of these mutations
indeed map in this surface and people
have actually learned that some of these
mutations increase or improve the
interaction and recognition of the of
the ac2
but really when you think about it there
is another domain in s
that is called the n terminal domain
which is very different than the one
interact with ac2 and there are many
mutations here that emerge during um
this um the emergence of these new
strains in the uk in south africa brazil
california and now the delta
that also contain mutations in either of
these domains
but
importantly
um
we know that is
this protein and this is the viral
genome here this protein is encoded here
in s
and but if you look at that the viral
genome is huge compared so this guy has
about five kvs um but the genome is
about 30 kb
and so focusing just in a small domain
here and s might actually be a mistake
uh what else is going on um and
we know now that from 28 viral proteins
seven have been recognized to modulate
immune immunoresponse and that's very
important because um viruses when it
gets to the next
ecological niche
the
critical thing is that they were able to
deal with the antiviral defense
mechanisms normally they have to
replicate but also they need to block
suppress
interferon or any other type of
antiviral response so and there are
mutations that occur occur
through the genome the question is how
do we integrate how can we we can
understand these mutations
so um i know that i'm i'm probably i'm
talking
more um time that what i should so let
me ask
you
you have another 50 minutes you're good
how many minutes
uh another
10 minutes okay so let me go very
quickly because i wanted to share with
you two different things that we've been
doing uh recently and one is uh trying
to use mathematical models that honestly
i learned from on the interaction with
leonid and
simoni bianco
two
people that i i interact uh over many
years and what we wanted to do and i
wanted to put this is uh you know very
top of my inverted pyramid the
epidemiological
aspect of this and that is you know
how is
non-pharmacological interventions can
help to
provide a solution to this epidemic and
the important thing is can we define
parameters to drive the epidemic
can we train the model with real
empirical data and then use additional
data to try to see whether it fits um
and how we can
examine elements that could
change the course of the epidemic in in
in ways that are effective to provide
these these solutions
and so
what we use here is very simple um a
stochastical uh stochastic
model and basically is like playing with
a
pacman
system in which
individuals
they actually
move
within a restricted area
in the surface and every time they
bounce against the wall they change
directions and they move that way that's
the simple
this is one individual and then you can
of course change the number of
individuals the size of the
of the um
environment
and so what we are interested in is
understanding uh this the dynamics of
the epidemic and what
we
consider is that when two individuals
one infected here uh
circled by red
um in contact
one individual that is uninfected at a
distance that is lower than two
radius so they are really in contact now
this guy has a probability to be
infected
and over 10 days it recovers
so let me just show you the um
the key here those are susceptible
individuals
and what we're going to try to
understand is the effect of mask and the
probability of transmission and the
course of the epidemic
and so in green are individuals that are
susceptible with mask
and then the red circle indeed indicates
you know individuals that are infected
and the probability of two
one in fact individual to transmit
the virus is given by this
factor alpha
that we calculate it's basically um a
way to determine the probability of
infection and it has a specific number
that has been uh
obtained based on experimental data
now if one of the individuals the
infected individual
is using a mask the probability of
transmission is reduced by this number
here 0.05
and if the mass is used by the
susceptible individual
sorry
the the
the mask is used by the
and
susceptible
individual
the infected then there is another
factor of 0.15 that
determine or reduce the probability of
infection
the important thing is that this type of
exercise enables to have a visualization
of the process and we as a primates
work best at um when you have a
visualization of the process that is
what inspire us the most to understand a
process numbers are more difficult
sometimes to understand so let me
remind you we have contact infection and
recovery and
depending if you are using mask or not
you have a probability of being infected
that is determined by this alpha
factor
and so
this
what you will see here is a panel where
nobody is using mask a panel where 40 of
people are using masks and a panel were
80 of people using mask and in this kind
of stochastic models of course you can
change the probability of infection
depending of many factors and adjusting
the fact of the model that way you can
change the number of people using mask
and so um
what you see now is the people moving
around and there's individual people um
the infected person and and this person
they move around and see as you see you
know this um
group of people with no mask get
infected very quickly and they have this
blue peak here
that is the number of people infected
per day and there's a critical parameter
because
the
important thing is that you don't want
to overwhelm the health system the
hospitals and so the flatter this blue
curve is the better
you can deal with the epidemics and you
can see that if every 80 percent of
people use mask that blue curve is
flatter than if nobody's using mask
now the other thing that people have
been considering is this um social
distancing and the way we
model social distancing is um
you know two individuals may be moving
with no social distance so they move
around randomly both of them but when
there is some social distancing some
proportion of the population does not
move anymore
and that reduces the probability of
encounter you know the
close encounter between between the
infected and non-infected individual and
so um this
simulates what would happen if you don't
go to work you stay home or you know or
you you you decide you know that you
know that you don't uh go to the grocery
store so often and so on
and when we use this now you will see
the same parameters greens using mask
blue not using masks different
proportion of mass use here and you will
see now when i start the movie that part
of the
population does not move in this
particular movie we're using
40 of people are staying home
and and what you see now
is see there's many people that are
sitting in their homes but there's other
people that are bringing the pizzas or
whatever they
are they are actually coming to the
thing but you know of course
because there is less chance that they
will encounter uh
each other you see that there is a
reduction of the number of
infected individuals per day so the blue
curve is a little bit um
smaller than the ones i i showed you
before but the best effect is when you
combine both things of course mask use
of mass reduce probability of infection
and
the people stay input and also reduce
the probability of transmission
at the other at the end of the day this
is a combination of these two studies
here you have in in red is wearing mask
and blue is 40 nowhere in mass blue is
40 percent 80 percent and here is social
distance 0.
this is very bad situation because you
have a peak of individuals coming out at
a particular
day at to the hospital so you overwhelm
the hospital as you increase social
decency you reduce
that red peak but if you use mask which
is 80 and green basically you know you
have very little
numbers of individuals infected now
really the question is um can you
maintain 80
of use of mask and 80 of decency and the
answer is obviously
there is no compliance of using mass and
then social distance has been
having an impact on
society and economy and so on
um but i just wanted to to
bring this
at the end to to this to these two
graphics
these are death per million people
and you see that if you compare a curve
where there's no social distance
or 80 of people um
use
this social is
not going to work
the two curves seems to respond to the
use mask this is zero to eighty percent
you can see that even though nobody
stay home you know the masks really have
a strong effect on reducing the number
of deaths of people
but that's not the case if you invert
the situation now you're looking social
distance here
and we're in mass 0 or 80
it's very high but there is but but
really the um the uh
the social distance if you don't wear a
mask doesn't seems to be affected as
much
and also of course the best is the
combination but um
the
mass seems to be more effective the more
people use mask more clearly uh you
change the probability of a pandemic to
expand
well i want i wanted to you know talk
about the um the second part which is
effective interferon particles because
this
and i will try to do it in in in last
last four or five minutes just touching
superficially very high on the idea of
um
the you know how this defective
interferon particles can uh be used as a
therapy and recombination is not a
perfect process like
any biological process and sometimes the
polymerase doesn't jump exactly to the
place where uh
at the same place but in the blue genome
but sometimes it jumped forward and
leonid was mentioning that often we see
deletions in this viral genomes
and so we wanted to understand that and
we create a deletion in uh one and this
is a
picorna virus um to create this um
defective interferon uh particle or dip
and the question was really you know can
we create a
therapy using this thing because it is
the effective different particle might
actually attenuate infection
and there was a collaboration between
judith friedman stanford leonid broski
from haifa
nakamura from aleph biotex
and simone bianco from ibm and
eliabroski and i i think it's
interesting because here there was three
academic institutions
interacting with
three
companies that provide different
[Music]
aspects and it was a very interesting
only a mixture of expertise but also
coming from different perspectives and
[Music]
areas
and
basically if you
co-inject
polioviruses with this defective
nutrient particle you protect here is
the co-infection and here is if you just
infect uh with the virus you can see
that you protect this this animal about
30 30 of the animals do not do not do
not survive charged with polio but more
than 90 percent survive
and that is because the virus cannot go
to the brain so in here is the brain
in solid lines you see a lot of um a lot
of um virus in the brain are day one and
day three and this is why the these
animals die because polio is a
neurotrophic virus but if you uh
co-infect with the etip you see no
virus in brain
and this also protect against other
viruses coxsackie and influenza
and
also protect against uh sars kobe 2 and
here you are doing an international
inoculation of this tip
and and then challenge with sarcoby ii
and these are highly susceptible animals
uh you see a reduction of about three
logs of um of virus in the lung and the
brain and you can see that the virus
replicates very well this is the amino
fluorescence using antibiotics against
the spike or the n or spike which are
those two proteins of the virus this is
three days
uh post infection this is six days post
infection and when you do the
co-infection you completely protect both
the lung
as well as the brain
and this uh therapy works
not only by
a prophylactic putting the the the the
the effective intuition particle before
but you can also use it therapeutically
so in this case we are putting the uh
the e-tip uh 24 hours or 48 hours
after infection and also works in
different strains that are circulating
this is the uk strain this is the
california strains this is the initial
u.s strain
now this is what i really wanted to to
tell you because i think at that this
point we wanted to understand you know
what was the nature of the protection
you know why this thing protects and it
turns out that we
did a very initial analysis using um
rna-seq data and it's very clear in this
volcano plot that there is a bunch of
genes in red here that corresponds to
genes of type 1 interferon
response and we use also animals that
don't are not able to respond to
interference and in that case
these
animals are not protected so the
conclusion really is that this defective
interfering particles do not work just
simply by competing with uh the
multivirus but actually create some sort
of antiviral state that um you know help
to eliminate uh the uh pathogenic virus
um and
basically
now we've been doing some analysis and
we need to go now with single cell
analysis but this is just
flow cytometry and what we we can see
in this analysis is that the virus is
affecting the way that it means immune
system responds to um the infection
there is some cells specific cells that
now are present in in the lung during
infection that were not present or
suppressed by cytoscopy too
so really what at the end of the day
what i think is
type of therapist is doing is changing
the
character of the immune system
from an inflammatory
condition which are represented by this
type of cells and we know that sars one
of the reasons why sars cause diseases
because in initiates inflammatory
response we think of the et this this
defective interferon genome what it's
doing is changing to an antiviral state
um and then coagulation is another
characteristics of the sars or the the
kovi 19 disease and you know we again we
think that is the balance between these
two lineages of
immuno cells
that are very important to control and
um age also
when you have with the age is another
factor of risk and what happens is when
people get older um there's a problem at
the
stem cell level where you start getting
more myeloid protein progenitors rather
than lymphoids and so again
understanding this process and this
balance and this
at the level of cell population will be
very important for this particular
disease there are many infectious
diseases uh particular viral diseases in
which the disease is the consequence of
the
imbalanced immunological response
um and i think i'm gonna have to um stop
here although this last part was is very
exciting and it's something about we are
developing with ilia uh broski but uh
i'm not gonna have enough time i i
believe um so
you know i'll stop here um
and i apologize
for being a little bit longer than i was
anticipating
no problem it's very exciting talks and
thank you for covering in such detail